[Music]
being my daughter there are things
beyond your understanding that you are
destined for
[Music]
oh god what time is it 3:00 a.m. you
ever have a nightmare and at the last
second you wake up and everything's okay
well this isn't one of those entire
kingdom got turned to stone
my mom's evil uncle who died good times
also wherever you are I'm sorry
this is heaven why did I waste all that
time being alive incoming necro chat for
mr. elf oh hello oh is that you you're
the one that called me you know I can't
get to heaven but if alpha can meet us
in hell I know way out think I think I
do but let me hot stuff
[Music]
that sounds kind of real there's a
prophecy to be fulfilled like mother
like daughter I'm not like you unless
you want to see something really cool
let's hide under this pile of children
and restored romantic glory whatever
happens you're gonna fight back
together we'll have to witness in a
dangerously half-assed manner that's the
dream that way
quick after the dragon and may the best
man slay it we're a woman let's not
ignore women here
[Music]